Stargate new series confirmed apparently
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now you will know if you're a regular
site tracker that we talk about Stargate
quite a lot and in fact this Channel
started by me talking about a story from
giant freaking robot a story that was
kind of true but kind of not true it got
a hundred thousand views it got us
enough attention on this channel for me
to get monetized really quickly and it
got me talking about Stargate but it
also taught me the lesson very quickly
the giant freaking robot are a bunch of
idiots they are monkeys at the zoo
throwing poo knowing that if they throw
enough poo occasionally they might
actually hit the target so a lot of
their stories are just nonsense made of
crap they take something that's popular
they write story about it they'll get
some clicks but occasionally they do
write stories though even though they
are technically true they're either
massively out of date or they just put
up a title that is incredibly misleading
so this is what's happened today and has
forced me to do this bloody video
because lots of people are asking me
whether it's true or not so
here we go Joe freaking robot in the
last couple of days has released a story
saying that Stargate has been confirmed
they are saying that Stargate has
actually been confirmed by Joseph malozi
now ages ago Joseph malozi was Tweeting
or he's actually on Reddit I believe and
he was answering a question the question
was is Target going to return and he
said Stargate is definitely going to
return with a new series he went on to
say look myself and Brad Wright had
nothing to do with it we're not involved
but Amazon are 100 doing it now
where did he get this information from
if he's not actually involved because I
happen to know for a fact Joseph malozi
and Brad Wright because I actually
talked about right occasionally he
responds to me sometimes
um are not involved they know nothing
about what's going on Amazon Amazon
don't talk to them and Brad Wright very
sweetly said the other day the last
thing I heard from MGM was I got a
Christmas card other than that no
contact
Joseph Willows is in the same boat what
Joseph malozi is actually confirming
there is a story that was released by
Sidetrack first
we release a story about the new series
in development and that penguin and a
Parker with Mark Fergus were involved in
that that was then discussed on dial the
gate and Jenny stiven who used to work
MGM who's a big deal particularly with
Target command Etc confirmed what we've
been saying that was then repeated by
pop cast now pop cast have quite a good
working relationship with Joseph malozi
so he did a basically a web page and he
said about how this had been confirmed
and he credited the pop cast guys thanks
very much
I'm not really surprised by that though
because Joseph velosi doesn't really
like this channel
um me and Joseph Williams he got into a
let's call it a debate
um about climate change and how climate
change is a problem I went on the side
of climate change is a bad thing and
that we should be worried about it Joe
from milosi went on the side of climate
change is not a problem and we should
worry more about jobs which is not
necessarily wrong the debate got
let's say passionate and we ended up
blocking each other
um it's one of those things we've don't
ever meet your Heroes it was a shame
Joseph malozi however got that
information basically from us that got
confirmed through a few cycles and he
repeated the story Weeks Later
giant freaking robot then got that story
they got that Reddit thing somehow
honestly months ago and released this
story today saying that it's confirmed
now I can actually tell you because if
you are a regular Star Trek you know
this is the place to go for regular
Target news
that the series is now a possibility
again now I'm going to do another video
talking about this because I need to get
a few things confirmed before I really
talk about it in detail but there are
two Studios kind of fighting over this
one is really pushing for the movie and
the head of Amazon pictures is sort of
Leaning that way at the moment and it's
actually gone as far as kind of
pre-ordering and moving but there is
another Studio that is pushing for the
series and there's basically a debate
going on about which way to go and it is
a big deal though because there's two
very different competing companies that
both have really good relationships with
Amazon and both have really good working
relationships with penguin and Parker so
we're not 100 certain Which Way Amazon
are gonna finally go on all we do know
is for a fact the giant freaking robot's
full of oh again I won't swear
so just to recap trying freaking robot
I've got this story you're going to see
a lot shared on Facebook pages Etc you
can ignore it I will tell you when
Stargate does get the final official
green light and to be honest
Amazon and MGM will tell you as well
so as soon as we get something that we
can really bite our teeth into and that
you can actually think seriously I will
tell you
but get into the comments guys tell me
what you are thinking what do you think
about the current state of the Stargate
where do you think Amazon are going to
finally land do you think they will go
for a movie whether you like it or not
or do you think they will go for the
series now I'm not asking you what you
hope for what you want what do you think
they will actually do I'd love to know
get to the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you will never miss any of
our new videos especially that big
Stargate announcement when we do finally
get to make it
also you can go to patreon forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
go first and for a small contribution
each month which really helps the
channel out you can get to see them
without the adverts
as always please keep yourself safe and
I'll see you soon
foreign